all right great thank you so much for
having me here my throat was itchy when
during the previous talk i got covered
and i was feeling it
anyway so in case i start to um
clear my throat and you know why
i clearly recovered right so i looked
okay now
um so anyway um so today i'm going to
tell you about our work as part of the
encode consortium and to continue
from our effort during the encode
consortium and today is going to be more
like um the evolutionary
aspect of these regulatory elements
that controls gene regulation
so just a little bit of motivation
so as you all know
1.5 percent of the human genome encode
for proteins and um we are really very
interested in regulatory elements
which is
we think the interesting bits of the
non-coding genome
and uh um so the reason we're interested
in regulatory elements is ultimately
we're interested in understanding
the variants
that differ among our genomes
how are they related to our phenotypes
the interesting thing is um these
genetic variants are highly enriched
in um regulatory elements so um and i
have a i have a pointer so actually it's
this one brighter okay
so um we are interested in regulatory
elements so just very um briefly
regulatory elements um in encode we call
them candidate cis regulatory elements
because these are defined using
epigenetic data or transcription factor
binding chip seek data so they're not
like thoroughly tested that's why
they're called candidate
and very often they include promoters um
which um promotes the transcription of a
gene
by interacting with um the proteins that
will bind to the promoter will interact
with the polymerase
the um enhancers they act at a distance
by um working through promoters
and there are silencers
and they are insulators so we we
commonly see
these different categories of um
regulatory elements and what i'm going
to talk about today includes all of them
so today's talk is not going to go into
like different types
but
um just as a whole they're all in part
of our consideration
so they are so interesting that um there
is a two-decade um encode project that
just ended earlier this year um
to chart
all these functional elements in the
genome and i have an old picture before
covid um when people are still
attending in-person conferences we had
one that was more virtual they don't but
you get the picture
so encode wanted to catalog functional
elements in the human and the mouse
genomes
and we were um
playing quite a bit of role in the data
analysis center of this project and so
the project generated
a ton of data and all freely available
at
encodeproject.org
and we um we actually had quite a lot of
fun analyzing the data and they for the
talk of today um i'm going to mention a
few data types one is um dna's seek
which detects open chromatin regions in
the genome and they are chip c comet and
immunoprecipitation followed by
sequencing they can be for
grabbing out the regions found by
transcription factors abbreviated as tfs
or histone modifications
and there are a bunch of transcription
data rna-seq various types
and
we
worked hard on defining the registry of
these cis regulatory elements
so um
so how do we define these
regulatory elements uh candidates
regulatory elements um i started out by
saying um they're candidate because we
use epigenetic data so exactly what do
we mean um by using epigenetic data
so these are like elements that are
nucleosome sites they're around 300 base
pairs long
and very commonly devoid of a nucleosome
and instead of the nucleosome they're
bound by
transcription factors and very often
they will be bound by multiple
transcription factors
up to 10 sometimes
we actually have uh
data to show that a distribution so if
you have um
antibody that specifically recognizes
one specific kind of transcription
factor you can chip it and then find our
way binds that's one way of detecting
these
regulatory elements
and encode has a bunch of these kind of
data
or
they are very often flanked by
nucleosomes that have a specific
histomodification pattern
itself is nucleosome free but the
neighboring nucleosomes have patterns
and you can also use
antibody to grab down those histo
modifications
and then map and find out the region
between them
to get these ccies
or
you can use essays like dnase which
detects open chromatin it basically cuts
open chromatic regions and then try to
figure them out where they are and the
map to the genome so
um we integrated a bunch of this kind of
data
that's generated by encode as you can
see here in a specific locus of the sp1
gene and we detect these regions like
300 base pair long regions in the genome
that correspond to
promoters that are open chromatin it has
histomark
enhancers and the
insulators they have a characteristic
histomark and
binding by
transcription factors such as ctcf which
is the
insulator binding protein in mammals
so we detect these ccres so as part of
encode 3 effort
so actually
a lot of work
was done by jill moore and michael
carroll and henry pratt here and henry
is sitting right there so if you have
any questions that i cannot answer go
ask him
so as part of the encode um we put
together a registry of nearly
a million ccies in humans and less for
bowels because we have less data for
mouse but having mouse and human enable
us to start to think about conservation
which kind of led to what i'm going to
tell you about because this is kind of
old news
um you you might have read about it but
but for us it's very old news but it
serves as a motivation
so if you um
take a look at these ccres and uh
you look at the the final p score so we
had in our hands at that time
was a phyllo p square across 100
vertebrate genomes
and you can see these different types of
ccies these are like promoter enhancers
different i'm not going to go into the
details here they are clearly more
conserved
than
random but they're actually not
impressive the reason i'm saying that is
because i'm not showing you the error
bar here if i were to show you the error
bar that would be like huge
right
this is mean
on every general consult but a lot of
them actually are not conserved
and if you compare the set we have
between human and mouse um
the human one is i mean it's a bit
misleading here because the mouse mouse
set is smaller due to the smaller amount
of data but in any case quite a bit of
it is um
like no homology between human and mouse
and homology only and then homology and
also ccie in the other species
so there is definitely conservation
but
not so impressive so
so for a while we kept on pondering over
this
um so um are these low therapy ccies
truly unconserved
or um the data we had for conservation
was across 100 vertebrates and it's a
low evolutionary distance perhaps um
some of these ccies will show
conservation
in more
recent evolutionary time right
so um we um
we got um involved in this uh zoonomia
consortium um which is um the project
that's led by shishan limbo atoll
and eleanor carlson um it just happens
that illinois is one of my faculty so we
were talking about this doing our
faculty research and she was like oh
you're you're looking at these kinds of
conservation why don't you try out our
um mammalian
genomes so they they have sequenced um
240 percentile mammals
and that possibly is a more recent
evolutionary time right we were like hit
it off right right away and uh um greg
was the one uh greg andrews is a
graduate student in my lab um was making
the presentation he must have done a
very good job so we got all roped into
um this is what i'm going to talk to
talk to you about today um this project
as part of the zoonomia consortium
so also kylie finn and again henry um
they are co-leading this um this
manuscript so we took the 200 mammal
phytop so indeed you see these solid
lines they are a lot higher than the
dashed lines the dashed lines are from
100 vertebrate in the previous part i
show you so it's quite a bit like three
times higher and we have hopes up so
this is great
um
so um
so one another advantage of um the
um
tsunomia data was um it has these um
um
reference free alignment
made by an algorithm called the cactus i
mean why would you use a plant to make
the alignment of mammals is beyond me
but anyway um so they have across the
240
percentile mammal um
alignment okay it's not
human specific
so which is better than
the vertebrate one we had before
so um we took the alignment
and
so kylie was the one who came up with
this um triangle representation so if
you take one ccre and you look across
all 240
species
okay so anyway it's it's a bit confusing
i don't know if i should get into it but
anyway just remember it's 240
genomes and they don't include the human
in this because these ccies are defined
in humans so by definition they're
already in humans so we're interested in
whether or not they are also aligned in
the other genomes
and the reason that it's still 240 is
because illinois is a dog person and it
has two dog genomes in there which is a
bit jarring and like a pure bread and
some kind of
crust anyway so so it's still 240 just a
tip-it
so if you take a ccre remember it's like
300 base pairs long and you can you can
have some kind of threshold as to what
percentage of the 300 base pairs need to
be aligned in another genome okay
depends on the threshold um you can say
90 of it has to be aligned okay and then
you count across the 240 genomes exactly
out of 240 how many would be able to
align more than 90
or more of the position and you can also
flip it and say how many of the genomes
really definitely don't align so less
than 10
less than 10 again of the 300 base test
right so by definition
every ccie
this is 0.92 million dots on this heat
map every cci needs to line this
triangle because they can't go out of it
just by design okay but the interesting
thing is three populations pop out
um group one we call them one group two
and group three and this is random if
you randomly picked regions in the
genome you can see there is an
enrichment in these um two regions
especially group one and group three
so as it turns out group one is um
highly conserved across mammals across
almost 240 mammals and group three is
private specific very primate specific
as you'll see in a minute it's very
interesting and group two is a mix i
don't know if um if you have questions
about it i can show you more parts but i
just don't want to get into all these
details without
confusing you yeah
oh and one is the number of species
number of genomes sorry and one is
number of genomes out of the 240
that can align at least 90
of the positions of a particular ccre
and two is um at most 10 percent
so m1 and n2
sum
up to at most 240 that's why it's on the
triangle
okay so so you can see that group one is
enriched we're very enriched so it's
half of the ccie is actually
enriched across all the memos
this is much more so than the vertebrae
which you will see in the next slide in
comparison
so did i answer your question i know
it's a bit of my interesting here
okay
ask me again okay um
so
okay we submitted paper and whatnot and
one of the reviewers was being very
annoying at first but turned out to be
actually very patient he was like
why do you think mamo's genome are you
are you sure it's helping you
what do you get if you um just use your
vertebrae genomes so we actually went
back and made this map with a hundred um
vertebrae genomes now it goes to from 1
0 to 99 you don't really show it because
human is is part of the 100
and out of the 100 vertebrae genomes
there are 68
mammal genomes just keep it in mind so
you see the blob moved from here to here
okay and this region is the part that's
conserved beyond the mammals
and if you really want to be very
stickler about the ones that are
conserved beyond mammals is this
triangle at the top left corner
and that is only 4.4 percent of our
ccies
okay so
basically you have to use the shorter
evolutionary distance if you really want
to
detect the conservation of these
elements they evolve very fast and if
you go beyond mammals you just don't
detect them you detect some really
really deeply conserved ones but very
low percentage and you can take these
map and then take each one the ccis in
each region and map to the mammals
triangle this is the same one that's
what i showed you previously and you can
see the ones
the ones vg0
vertebrate group geo it's like at the
pinnacle of this triangle it's hugely
conserved so anyway by using the mammals
data we we really are at a very sweet
spot for detecting conservation
so
okay um here comes another reviewer
which is was really really annoying hey
it's like
i mean
for a week i was very annoyed by him and
i was losing my my epitaph because he
says there's really nothing wrong with
the paper but i just don't like it
um you know how you do this opposite
thing you know you start with your
alignment you're not using the alignment
you're doing all this averaging
so okay we did something following the
reviews usually you know reviewers they
just just they don't help in a lot of
the papers it turned out to be this one
was really helpful
so we took the um
alignment
so each ccie can be represented as an
alignment a percent alignment across all
240 genomes right
and then we throw this thing into umap
and if you still remember group 1 group
2 group 3 in that triangle heat map and
they show up i was like whoa what is
this
so group one remember it's the
across all mammals conserved
and then group two
is the one at the lower left it's a
mixed bag we call them actively evolving
and group three is primary specific
the reason it's primary specific we have
all the alignments they effectively
only show up in primates so out of the
240 genomes we have 42 primates
plus
three
nearest non-primate genomes
they're very weird things i actually
learned a lot of biology about these
things um the closest one
is um sunda
flying
um
lima which is neither fine nor a lima
right and it's this naked looking thing
with a canopy on top that can go live
like 250 meters from some tree i don't
know why you need to do that but in any
case for like 50 years
people thought it was a mammal and just
got recently disqualified
so anyway all these tidbits aside and
these group three elements they
basically explode into little clusters
right
and you can color this your map by like
number of genomes stay on high and it's
like fascinating depends on what
fraction of the lens you require you
have heard the number of 90 and 10
percent
right so if you color by 10 90
like they align the number of species
that align is like at the tip here
if you change the threshold to be a
little more lenient you see the red kind
of crept up
so again like one of the reviewers was
asking like how like you know you're
making all these arbitrary decisions in
90 percent 10 percent like what happens
if you change the threshold there you go
a group two is actually this thing it
changes this is green ones when you
change the threshold
it aligns more so if you if you require
50 to be aligned the group two elements
actually get aligned in across like 170
genomes so they really are very
interesting mix
and then of course we can start to color
this thing by um
other
possible genomic function like filo p
score so final p score
alignment is um doesn't have like a
mutation rate in it so by design phyllo
phylo ps4 has a mutation rate of the
different branches of the tree um
already in the model and so um
we think it's a
it's a more accurate model you'll see in
a minute when we switch to transcription
factor binding sites but you see the the
group one the most conserved one at the
tip
um have
the highest fellow p score and you can
color it by the distance to the nearest
transcription star side you see these
things start to show up
like even the most um conserved ones
they don't have to be promoters but
promoters tend to be more conserved
and when you overlap with transposable
elements
right like the group three really are
pretty much
the majority of the ones that
group three here are derived from
transposable elements
so um i'm going to switch to
transcription factor binding sites um
just to show your related results so as
part of encode
we have um
yeah henry here again um built this
resource called the facto book you might
have used before um take the chip seek
data generated by encode and then
annotate as much as possible motif all
kinds of things out of it so so we
already
in our wheelhouse we already have um
collections of transcription factor
binding sites all curated
so we took
367
tfs really the curated sites of these
transcription factors
and now they are um smaller they're like
between seven to 20 base pairs big
so one ccr you can have a lot of
transcription factor binding sites in
indeed just keep that in mind so it's a
higher resolution picture of um
gene regulation
so this is
one out of um the 367 tfs we looked at
it's a little specific hnf 4a
transcription factor and this is the
corresponding year map
okay um
remember the one with um
ccre is still again
red green and blue for the three groups
red is highly conserved across all
mammals
green is the mixed cluster mixed group
and then blue is
um primate specific so we have these 42
primates plus like three other species
um i i mentioned the fine lemur the
other two are
three shoes
in case you're interested so here is the
primate part of the tree so the tree is
longer we just truncated it to show only
the primate part
okay so you can see that
all these clusters
indicate
different evolutionary
combinations
like a here
it's only in grade eights
you don't have to be able to read it but
if you zoom in you can see all the data
with percentages and all that but but
just just um look at the color red means
it's there and then blue means
accent if you look really carefully it's
it's not like 50 50 it's more like 90
and 5
so it's really clean cut so this cluster
is only in gray apes and b
will
b
is only in gray apes and old world
monkeys and c is in gray apes and
new world monkeys but not in old world
monkeys and d
is in gray apes and monkeys okay e
now extend to
um lima like monkeys
and f now includes those three
interesting um non-memos
okay so you can look at the each cluster
there they're like
every each way you can imagine
finding space
it's just a sequence level
plus
oh they're from uh yes yes yes the data
from humans is from chip seek but in
other species it's only sequence level
conservation
that's a really good question i'll show
some data
for for for some of these
okay but they are um
yeah i mean it's complicated they may
not be bound about
the ones that have sequence conservation
we believe it's still boned
in other species
okay just hold on your question if i
don't answer it ask me again later
so um if you look at these clusters
again um if you look at the transposon
element you see these waves of
transposable elements so these are the
the the same classes i'm talking about
before and
like um line one element here line one
is among the youngest transposable
elements in our genome and line two is
old very old um
aloe aloe is sign is
also very recent
mir is um
is is sign but ancient
and ltr is long terminal repeat
containing element is young
and dna element is old so you can see
like the waves of them just bringing in
the sides
into the human the primate lineage um
differently for for the size of one
factor and if this is not like hnf 4a
specific if you look across like the
tfs we have data for for each one of
them we have a heat map we have all
these things you can see they basically
tell the same story
and this is a aggregate plot
across all the tf binding sites there
are 15.6 million of them defined in
human and you can see that if it's group
three
86.1 percent of them
are derived from transposable elements
and they are basically innovations of
um
transposable elements during the primate
lineage
and mostly contributed by these young
t's
line 1 lu and ltr elements
um so um
because um because the resolution for
for transcription factoring sites is
much higher than for ccres which i
showed you if you still remember the
plot before the continuous portion the
portion that's not group 3
is quite continuous but for
transcription factors this is more
likely
the case with like
lobes coming off
for um other elements and you can see um
this is uh fox a1 binding sites
and these um
lobes of them and you can see there
they're lost like one here is lost in
bats
and two lost in new world monkeys again
red means present blue means absent
um
three is this low
was lost in situations these are whales
and
platypuses oh okay
sorry
oh time's out okay
okay you can see you see the picture and
i'm gonna skip this and i can answer
tian's question so at the at the end
okay so here is um chip seek data from
other species
and
the ones that are this is the percentage
of constraint sites we actually came up
with a way of defining
subsets of them that are
conserved
across the species and a subset of them
we we think we know um which ones are
conserved and they are likely to be
bound and likely to be functional
and this is chip c data across species
and the constrained ones are likely to
be bound
okay likely to leave footprints
of um dna's cleavage
and at the end i have to say this but um
in order to get to my punch line i do
have a punchline besides a couple of
pictures
um so we did ld score regression for all
these sites
um here are the tsunomia conserved
elements and we derived a set of
conserved elements using a two component
gaussian model in one of the sides that
i skipped over so so anyway we define
the ones that we think are conserved
with a better definition using trees and
mutation rate
and they are
highly enriched in human traits
okay so the enrichment in the human
trade
is the most
prominent when you have the highest
conservation
um
and it's cell type specific for the
traits so we have
um thyroid traits regular cell traits
and then other immune traits they
correspond to different cell types so
i'm just going to conclude before
i get some of the platform so the
conclusions i have a very long
conclusion but anyway i just want to
tell you that what what i really want to
tell you is um so if you look at the
human regulatory elements
um about one fifth like 20 percent of
them
are
recent in the innovations in the climate
lineage by transposons
okay however
that's not what's causing all our
problems with our traits so however it's
the opposite
the most deeply conserved elements
across
all mammals which constitute about 1 8
of all of our elements
those are the ones that explain human
traits
that's it
yes
fascinating to see this
in the late 2000s there was a lot of
work from eddie google's lab on what
kind of constraints sequence constraints
so we published a lot of papers then
showing that mammalian constraint
is what you should use for
a million regulatory elements
[Music]
if you just look at conservation and of
course the primary specific elements
will be transposons correct right
but if you look at constraints
so the
vast majority of transposons are not
constrained
99 of them are not constrained
99.9 also groups we are not constrained
it's exactly the same as we said
actually much more
more you know
if you use primates
that gives you a better idea of the
conserved function and if you don't get
constrained when it comes out is that
its bosons and non-transposons are the
same
they equally likely give
so this is the site i skipped over and
you can see the contribution it's like a
bimodal distribution we did this for
each of the tf and we defined the other
mode that's constrained
is it primary constraint no this is
mammal constraint
good suggestion thank you
so even more money again so the encode
data has about 680
yeah so um
has more than what i talk about um so
basically here we show them three six to
seven of them because we we're quite we
have curated a set with no teams so we
understand what they are and encode has
more data
more transcription factors because
they're pretty depleted for existing
thinner class which is less well studied
yeah people are doing in vitro
experiments to try to find
right so can you take that information
and kind of feedback that back into a
nucleus of occupancy data and other
things from the encode project to try to
infer whether those sites are actually
occupied
trying to tie them to whatever
transcription factor you know like
usually we have yeah these are the crabs
and fingers i skip to the side yeah yeah
so we have 69 of them in our collection
and we actually learned quite a bit
about them
um but they're bound so so they are
definitely about in humans
it's just they are recent intentions so
they're less
less likely to be bound um
beyond priming yeah
yeah and they have more of a link to
transposons
because they're yeah exactly percent
transportable element of
overlap with disposable elements though
yeah
bigger ones they're all way higher
yeah
they have very different features too
they're more real to repress transposons
while others are being spread around by
transport
so
if you look whether
these different types of contrast
elements are also concerned the
association between
this is here
i was going to go to talk to eric and
use this dna data has the highest need
data on a lot of mammals we have not
looked at them yet
yeah
okay so next step
so i thought that was really impressive
the explanatory power developed using
explicit evolutionary treaties and
looking declaration f4a binding sites so
i was wondering what you thought about
flipping the analysis you did the first
step we were trying to lump all the 240
different um
uh mammals and whether you're looking at
those in the context of the details of
the trees for that or something that's
about original story there
we have like two sets of parallel
analysis
one is for ccres which are bigger and
less
lower resolution
and you can you can actually see they
are more continuous and then each one is
like a combination i haven't shown them
to one it's like it's a combination of
different groups of transcription factor
writing sites
so which kind of limited uh analysis
that's why
more analysis was done in tfps
and that's why i show you more of it but
we have done both analyses there in the
big picture they they are similar to
each other
emotions are pretty much the same
james still have a question yeah um
so the question is about um so you you
completely rely on the sequence
alignment to call whether that position
is conserved okay what is
they might jump to neighboring sides
yeah the sequence level the binding side
but the
exact you know the line to the columns
alignment may not be
back to some of the
elements that
don't show the high of the
say apology constitution
level
the sequence level is not that concerned
but functionally it is concerned
it's possible yes we didn't have the
power to pin those down i mean we have
some kind of way of allowing sound
movement in the alignment but we didn't
explicitly look for them in the
neighborhood to see if they're still
there
yeah that's a legitimate
maybe it's time to thank you for it
thank you so much